- What brought you back
down there? (laughs)
- Well, I wouldn't have
missed it for the world.
To be with Sam and Laura again, you know?
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
- Oh my god, they've changed my life.
I'd be a different person
if I'd never met them.
They're great artists and great people.
And then Colin Trevorrow,
who wrote it along with Emily Carmichael,
devised this very good way
to bring us all together.
I'd been a fan of hers,
I'd been a fan of his.
Campbell Scott is in it, Dichen Lachman,
Omar Sy is back.
And it's just a great cast.
- Yeah.
- And Steven Spielberg
is still the godfather
watchin' over the whole thing
from the start to the finish.
And over the decades
I'd seen people come up to me and go,
"Oh, my kids have seen it 100 times."
- [Kelly] Oh, mine have.
- It's meant so much to us.
I just love everything about it.
- Yeah, I agree. I agree.
(audience applauding)
It's a family favorite.
And it's generational, that's
what's so cool about it.
So y'all are new.
And I was gonna say, DeWanda,
I love your character.
- Thank you.
- I was like, "Oh, she gonna be badass."
I was like, "Show me the character!"
I was very excited about it.
Did you love becoming a part of this?
- Yeah, it's to your point.
I mean, it's the greatest
franchise of all-time.
- [Kelly] It is!
- I just feel really fortunate
that I was back, in this beyond epic way,
bringing back the legacy characters.
I feel very, very grateful.
- Yeah.
And Mamoudou, this is your
first time doing this too,
so what was it like to be a part of it?
- It was nuts, yeah.
- Is it kind of intimidating?
'Cause you're walking on
set and you're like, "Okay."
- Yeah, my first day on
set was with Laura and Sam.
I grew up with them watching...
This was the first big blockbuster movie
I ever saw as a kid, so to see them...
And I admired them as
actors forever as a kid
and as an adult.
To see them as those characters
and work opposite them,
I constantly found myself just like,
"Wait, am I really here?
Is this a real thing?"
But they really made
it just so comfortable
and a really pleasant experience,
as did these guys.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's awesome.